[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta especial donde
trataremos la situación de los indígenas
latinoamericanos tras la llegada de
gobiernos de izquierda los nuevos
mandatarios de chile Brasil y Colombia
traen Esperanza a los pueblos indígenas
que tradicionalmente han sido olvidados
por el estado Gabriel borich Gustavo
Petro y ahora Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
han prometido solucionar los problemas
estructurales pero no es una tarea fácil
ya que las mismas comunidades esperan
que sus territorios sean devueltos como
en chile o que la presencia del Estado
ayude a evitar el desplazamiento y las
zonas donde viven sean seguras como en
Colombia o que en la selva amazónica
llamada el pulmón del mundo se evite la
deforestación
las mapuches de chile tienen un
conflicto Centenario desde que el estado
decidió apropiarse de sus tierras y
convertirlas en plantaciones madereras
recientemente el gobierno de Gabriel
borich que asumió la presidencia el 11
de marzo ha prometido un cambio veamos
en este informe de Andrés triviño Qué
pasa actualmente en la región de la
araucanía
una lucha centenaria por la tierra en la
región de la araucanía chilena en el
centro del país los indígenas mapuche
aún piden que sus derechos sean
respetados se trata de una zona que está
en conflicto desde el siglo XIX cuando
el estado inició la anexión de más o
menos el 90% de sus tierras ancestrales
que eran unas 10 millones de hectáreas
solamente dos grupos
económicos tienen cerca de 2 millones de
hectáreas y un pueblo como donde hay más
de un millón de personas que se
autodentifica como mapuche
no tiene más de 600 mil hectáreas en el
país los han tenido que afrontar la
colonización de los españoles
Posteriormente la conformación de los
estados de chile y al otro lado de la
Cordillera de Argentina de Donde fueron
expulsados casi en su totalidad pero los
peores momentos fueron durante la
dictadura de Augusto pinochet cuando
otras tierras fueron confiscadas y
entregadas a empresas madereras que
siembran pino y Eucalipto y consumen
grandes cantidades de agua cada vez es
más difícil digamos para ello poder
hacer recolección de plantas medicinales
en la medida que los cultivos forestales
han invadido todos los nichos ecológicos
las comunidades indígenas basan su
supervivencia en la agricultura
tradicional la pesca la ganadería la
recolección de alimentos y madera de los
bosques la industria forestal de chile
es vital para la economía del país
contribuyen más de un 3% al pib Nacional
recientemente el gobierno del
izquierdista Gabriel Boris visitó la
zona y prometió cambio para los mapuches
esta será una comisión con una agenda
abierta
demanda de tierras de las comunidades
mapuches y proponerle al país mecanismos
concretos
con plazos concretos para saldar y
reparar esta deuda que el estado de
chile tiene con el pueblo mapuche en un
plazo que acordemos antes de la visita
de Boris opositores mapuches realizaron
un ataque incendiario el cual fue
catalogado por el gobierno como
terrorista muchos esperan que se remedie
la deuda histórica mientras experimentan
discriminación racial y social en todo
el país como lo podemos ver en este
primer caso el cambio no se nota aún en
este país donde la problemática de la
repartición de tierra y su privatización
sigue vigente después de chile pasamos
ahora a Colombia donde la situación es
parecida además donde el país fue
sacudido por más de 60 años de conflicto
interno y más Precisamente en el cauca
que es una de las regiones azotada por
años de violencia tras el conflicto
armado las comunidades indígenas han
tenido que abandonar sus tierras ya que
se encuentran entre el fuego cruzado de
los grupos armados ilegales
nuestros periodistas y Luis Muñoz
estuvieron en Santander de quilichao y
hablaron con el director de la unidad de
restitución de tierras sobre las
políticas que ha implementado Gustavo
Petro en cuanto a este tema tras su
llegada al poder el 7 de agosto de este
año
lo que está liderando nuestro presidente
de la república Gustavo Petro y nuestra
vicepresidencia Francia Márquez es
precisamente la posibilidad del
ejercicio de la reconciliación como
somos capaces nosotros de erradicar ese
proyecto de muerte que han traslapado
históricamente los gobernantes y con y
que sobre ese conflicto han logrado
sostener el poder en el régimen nacional
ahora como logramos acabar el conflicto
avanzar en un proceso de Reconciliación
para que sea precisamente la armonía y
la paz la posibilidad de la convivencia
social en Colombia y avanzar en la
posibilidad de una reforma agraria
integral
además de esto para Giovanni la
restitución de tierras es solo un
proceso de reparación y la reforma
agraria que busca el gobierno es mucho
más ambiciosa la restitución es
regresarle la tierra y el territorio a
las personas a las cuales se les ha sido
despojada por actores de la violencia y
el conflicto armado pero el tema de la
Reforma es que el gobierno del Estado
debe darle tierras a las personas que
necesitan en el campo para que puedan
hacer su vida mínimamente digna en el
marco de sus derechos fundamentales eso
significa que la restitución Es parte
precisamente
del del caminar hacia el equilibrio y la
armonía que debemos de tener la sociedad
colombiana en el sentido de que nos
corresponde hacer la reparación a las
víctimas del conflicto armado y esta
reparación se haría en la medida en que
vuelvan a tener pues
[Música]
espiritual social política y económica
en sus territorios de origen a cuatro
meses de la llegada del nuevo presidente
de izquierda Gustavo Petro es un poco
temprano para establecer un balance
pasamos a Brasil allí hablamos con
celiaba y le preguntamos sobre el nuevo
gobierno de Lula quien ha dicho que
habrá un cambio y Qué acciones concretas
Espera que tome el nuevo mandatario para
llevarlo a la realidad
en los primeros cien días de gobierno es
muy importante la demarcación de por lo
menos siete territorios indígenas y que
no exista ningún impedimento jurídico
estuvimos en la cop 27 junto al
presidente Lula entendiendo que los
pueblos indígenas Somos la única
solución para combatir la crisis
climática Y si Brasil está en el centro
del debate del tema climático
la demarcación de las tierras indígenas
es la principal
el principal solución
no se puede pensar en combatir la crisis
climática sin pensar en eso
el domingo también entregamos el
documento de la creación del Ministerio
de los pueblos indígenas el documento
final con 11 puntos de alerta para el
gobierno especialmente la situación de
la deforestación la minería ilegal y la
vulneración de los Derechos Humanos
entregamos también entregamos también
nueve alertas de leyes que impactan
directamente sobre los territorios
indígenas dentro del 001 que es lo que
regula el marco temporal de los que
serán reconocidos como territorios
indígenas que fueron los reconocidos
durante la Constituyente de 1988
Celia nos respondió sobre cuál es la
situación actual en términos de
seguridad de los pueblos indígenas de la
amazonía
tenemos una situación de mucha
vulnerabilidad porque principalmente en
estos últimos cuatro años de gobierno
este se comprometió con la política de
Exterminio ya hablamos con Lula de que
Brasil no solo perdió prestigio y
protagonismo internacional en relación
con la cuestion ambiental porque
nosotros también tenemos ese prestigio y
protagonismo y protagonismo
en 2019 lanzamos jornadas indígenas
recorrimos 12 países 25 ciudades y
denunciamos en el tribunal de la haya de
Países Bajos al gobierno por el crimen
contra la humanidad hicimos estas
jornadas en Francia Italia Alemania
Noruega discutimos en el parlamento
europeo que no se podía ratificar el
acuerdo del mercosur en los términos del
momento porque sería premiar al gobierno
de bolsonaro En aquel momento
y ahora en la copa nosotros tuvimos una
noticia buena finalmente que era
importante crear una ley de
rastreabilidad y vimos que en el
parlamento europeo están abiertos a
probar una ley contra la deforestación
pero infelizmente para nosotros no se
consideraba La Floresta y otros biomas
en Brasil hay seis biomas y es
importante reconocer en los seis
porque si no se hace es legalizar la
deforestación
y la deforestación y la invasión de los
territorios hoy es responsable de la
mayor violación de derechos
en este momento
en 2019 asesinaron a 135 líderes
indígenas y en 2020 asesinaron a 184
este panorama que acabamos de describir
no parece muy alentador para los pueblos
nativos del continente latinoamericano y
hay que dar tiempo a esos gobiernos
recién llegados para que puedan combinar
sus políticas con las necesidades de la
crisis ambiental que vive el mundo hasta
aquí este especial gracias por
acompañarnos sigan con más información
en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]